- [Instructor] We are
asked over which interval
does g have a negative
average rate of change?
So like always, pause this video
and see if you can have a go at this
before we do it together.
Alright, now let's do it together.
So there's a couple of ways
that we can conceptualize
average rate of change
and then think about negative
average rate of change.
So the average rate of
change for a function
let's just imagine a function really fast
and this isn't necessarily g of t
but that's our t-axis
and let's call this our y-axis
and let me draw y is equal to g of t.
Let's say it looks something like that.
So this is y is equal to g of t
my hand just drew g of x without thinking,
g of t right over there.
And let's say we are
concerned about the interval
from t equaling zero
to t equaling whatever this
value is right over here.
So what you do is you'd say, okay
what is our function equal
at the left boundary?
Well it looks like it equals that
and what is our function
equal at the right boundary,
it looks like it equals that
and then you could think about,
well, what is the slope of the line
that connects those two points
and that slope, the slope of this line
would be our average rate of change.
So in this example, it looks like
it's slightly upper sloping.
So this would have a positive
average rate of change.
On the other hand, if we
tried to look at the interval
from here to say here,
well then, we'll be looking at this point
and this point, and that clearly
has a negative average rate of change.
You can view the average
rate of change is,
what is your change and why
per change in t in this case?
Sometimes we would say change in x,
whatever the horizontal variable is.
So there's a couple of
ways to approach it.
The easiest way that I could
think of approaching this one
is setting up a table.
So let's put the t-values here
and let's put the g of t values here.
And let's see, on the left boundaries,
they have zeroes and ones.
So let's think about when t equals zero,
let's think about when t equals one,
and on the right, they
have four, six, and eight.
So I'll go four, six, and eight.
And let's just evaluate our function
on all of these points.
So what is g of zero?
Well this is going to be
equal to zero minus three,
so negative three squared
which is positive nine
plus two which is equal to 11.
What is g of one?
Let's see, one minus three
is negative two squared
which is equal to positive four plus two
which is equal to six.
G of four
is equal to four minus
three which is one squared
which is one plus two is equal to three.
G of six is equal to
six minus three is three
you square that, you get nine
plus two is 11.
And then last but not least,
g of eight is going to be equal to
eight minus three is
five, you square that,
you get 25 plus two is equal to 27.
So let's think about it,
when we go from t equals zero
to equals six, so going from t equals zero
to t equals six,
our g of t goes from 11 to 11.
So here, we have a zero
average rate of change.
On average over that interval,
the value of our function has not changed.
So that's not going to be a
negative average rate of change
so I'll rule that one out.
What about going from zero to eight?
So when we go from zero to eight,
the value of g of t goes from 11 to 27.
So as we increase t, we've
also increased g of t
so that's a positive
average rate of change,
not a negative one,
I've ruled that one out.
What about when we go from one to four?
So let's see, when we increase t by three,
it looks like we're
decreasing g of t by three.
So here, we have a negative
average rate of change.
If we were to visualize it,
we would see a negative slope
connecting this point and this point.
And so this would be our choice.
And we could verify the last one.
So when you go from t equals one to six,
from one to six,
so your t is increasing by five
and your g of t is also
increasing incidentally by five.
So there, you have a positive average
rate of change as well so we could rule
that one out as well.